let's bring in anchor of the story
martha mccallum is here martha we've
been watching every minute of this
throughout the day uh so far your your
take on the first public accounting of
that afghanistan withdrawal watching the
top military brass so you know obviously
they're in a difficult position because
all of these gentlemen all of these top
military advisors advised president
biden to leave 2 500 troops on the
ground uh they
did not get their wish and as you heard
from general milly he said you know i'm
not going to resign just because my
advice isn't listened to giving advice
is what i'm here to do i thought it was
very interesting at one point he said
you know my father didn't resign at iwo
jima and those 13 servicemen did not
resign at the abbey gate so he stuck to
carrying out his mission as he saw it
but on three very significant points
it's quite clear that all of these top
military brass disagreed with president
biden and the things that he is on the
record for having said one he said that
he never he didn't recall ever being
told that he should leave 2 500 troops
he could have said in that moment um yes
that was advice that i was given um but
that is not the one the decision that i
decided to make he said i don't recall
anyone telling me that he also said on
the record that al qaeda was gone
we heard today from these individuals
who are very close to the situation that
they say al-qaeda is not gone and in
fact presents a growing threat
they also took i think issue with the
extraordinary success
definition by president biden in saying
that it was a logistical success and a
strategic failure
so there's a lot of daylight i think
between these top military officials and
president biden as much as they tried to
sort of carefully tread that ground
including in this one exchange between
senator tom cotton and the defense
secretary austin on the input that these
military leaders were giving the
president listen
president biden last month in an
interview with george stephanopoulos
said that no military leader advised him
to leave a small troop presence in
afghanistan
is that true i believe that
first of all i know the president to be
an honest and forthright man is that
true or not their input was uh
was received by the president and
considered by the president uh for sure
obviously an exchange that stood out
yeah i mean that that's a contradiction
they're saying we absolutely told him
and he did listen to us uh he heard what
we had to say um so you know the thing
is that there's there's consequences to
that decision to not leaving people in
we now haven't gotten as many as 4 000
americans and sivs out of the country we
now have an accelerated threat from
terrorist groups including al qaeda and
isis k in afghanistan that they had
argued
could be contained or managed to a
greater extent if we left 2500 troops on
the ground so the consequences are ever
changing and moving just because you
decide you're going to leave on a
certain date and it was also interesting
general milley said i was always taught
uh and and you know raised to believe as
a military man for 42 plus years that
you never set a date certain so there's
a lot of controversy a lot of dissension
between these top military advisors and
president biden and president biden you
know
owns those decisions um and can stand up
for them but what we learned today in in
more sharp clarity i think is just how
deep those divisions were you talk about
the consequences here's uh chairman
millie doing just that saying that the
enemy controls kabul watch
outcomes like this are not determined in
you know the last five days the last 20
days or the last year for that matter
outcomes in a war like this
an outcome that is a strategic failure
the enemy is in charge in kabul
and that we know today martha right
strategic failure the enemy is in charge
in kabul and we watched all of that play
out with such great frustration i
thought it was interesting i think it
was tommy tuberville senator uh who said
you know can can the united states
military defeat any force on the face of
the earth essentially and
the answer was yes um so that puts you
in a situation where you're saying we
had an option to not leave the taliban
in charge of afghanistan uh had we
potentially brought in more troops or
had we potentially secured
maintained our presence at uh at the
airport at bagram air base there's a lot
of a lot of uh obvious questions that
you can go back and look at but the the
bottom line is i think most americans
feel this way that if we wanted to we
could have defeated the taliban
but there have been decisions all on the
way and i think they're right when they
say this is 20 years and several
presidencies four presidencies of
decisions that have gone into where we
are today lots of um notes too from the
um the members of congress they're
talking about where we stand on the
world stage as a result of this botched
withdrawal the joint chat chief's
chairman said that because of this
withdrawal
we have damaged our credibility here for
america as we await this to continue
martha you're going to stand by with us
thank you